I think I have a solution.
On an unknown issue
This is a question that no one will look for answers.
But I think I found one
There is a thing called 10958 problem
In order to express this question, I decided to start with a little math trick.
Some digital techniques
Just like those great digital tricks, you have to start by picking a number.
Can you give me a three-digit number first? What do you like to pick, pick one?
[Brady: "814."]
814, interesting, no problem.
Then can you give me a single number? Which number do you like?
He can be one of these three digits, or it can be brand new, any number you like.
[Brady: "2."]
2, no problem. This is what I am going to do next.
So, I can tell you 814 equals
22 times (2 plus 2 plus 2) to the 2nd power plus 22
If you don't believe it, we can test it again.
2 plus 2 plus 2 is 6. I think this is known as this
Then the square of 6 is 36
So we need 22 by 36 plus 22
22 times 36 equals 792
Add 22 equals 814, end!
You give me a three-digit number, then I can write his formula and just use the one you gave me.
Do you want to do it again?
[Brady: "Good"]
no problem! What three digits do you want this time?
[Brady: "998."]
998! You gave me a big, but not so big number.
What is the number of the one you plan to use?
We used 2 last time.
[Brady: "1."]
1, oh my god, you are really -- now, obvious
I can cheat and write directly, equal to 1+1+1+1...
That's right, and I can finish this formula there.
Because you have chosen an even number, 2, so I can also write 2+2 last time...
But the goal of this trick is to write it in the shortest formula.
So I can write 998 equals 11 minus 1, which is 10
Plus 1+1+1 power, 呃
Hey, I wrote two plus signs, then when he is a big plus, Oh, that’s a pretty plus.
Then, that is 10 to the 3rd power, 1000 minus 1 minus 1, then I did it!
We succeeded in making 998
I can do it all day.
In fact, I will
But everyone will close the film soon.
I can tell you why I can easily calculate the three digits you gave me with any number you gave.
Because I have a stack of paper underneath
Have all the combinations in it
So this is a one-digit representation of natural numbers
One person is called Taneja
I must have missed it. He is a Brazilian
So I definitely missed his name.
This is a lot of three-digit forms and how to write them out using formulas.
So this is all three digit numbers and 4 is used to write the formula
Then look here, use 6 or 5, any number you want to check
So the reason I can write these is because I am cheating
If you want to cheat, this is very straightforward.
You need 1 or 2 months to remember these
Then you can cheat in your head!
This is a wonderful thing to do, you know, the human brain
You can remember your cheats and cheat, and you can watch cheat sheets at any time without anyone knowing.
This is a loophole in life.
You can cheat by memory
[Brady: "This is called learning."]
Also known as...learning, you can learn from himTM, then you do it, yes.
[Brady: "So do we know that these are the shortest words? I mean, how does he use some rigorous way to prove that those are the shortest ways?"]
This is a great question
I don't make
He said that these are the shortest
I forgot if he said that these are the "real" shortest
Or the shortest one he found
He only said that there must be the shortest formula
I don't know how he confirmed these
So if you believe this guy
These are the shortest, but they may, I mean...
I believe in him
Does he stop here?
Oh, no
No, no, no, he took another step forward.
So let's continue to look at other tricks.
Try any number below 11111
[Brady: "7415."]
7415, no problem. So I can tell you that this number can be written as
This is another book, this one is a bit thicker.
So, this book is probably more than 160 pages, and then I have to use it directly this time.
Let us look for it
[Brady: "Do you remember this one?"]
I don't have time to remember this one, you know
You know, if I can take a vacation on the beach, I can sit there and remember this one too.
Hey, you picked a great number!
This requires subtraction
Not all numbers will be subtracted
[Brady: "You didn't ask me the number this time, my one is a number"]
You don't need to choose a single digit this time, because we have to use all the digits this time.
So you say 7415, 7415 can be
Negative 1 plus 2 by 3456
Add 7 times 8 times 9
or
He equals
Brackets 9 brackets 8 times 7 plus 6
Multiply by 5 brackets by 43, last bracket
Multiply 2 plus 1
Ok, so this is your number written in ascending order
That is, 1 to 9 are in order
Or can also be written in descending order, that is, from 9 to 1
Use only multiplication, addition, division, and subtraction
There is a power
So, using only simple calculations, this guy also found
All numbers less than 11111, only simple arithmetic symbols, ascending and descending ordering methods
[Brady: "This guy is legendary!"]
This guy is very legendary. I like this guy.
And he just did it. Also placed directly on the network. You can find his files directly.
That's right, if it's me, I will post it. But I will give a free version
You can only get the ascending version but you have to pay to get the descending order.
This is a paid version
That's right, or you can't get the middle part
Now, you may have discovered the name of this film.
This has a problem
Also known as the 10958 problem
If you query, let us look at 10958
So this should be at the bottom of the right
So he is here. This is 10958 written in descending order
But if we look at his ascending order,
He has not been discovered yet.
[Brady: [pour a breath]]
This is the only gap where all numbers are less than 11111
This is the first difference that you see. When you look at it, everything starts from 1 and until the end, the calculations are there.
Then you stop in one place: not found yet
[Brady: "So this is like Achilles' ankle"]
That's right, Achilles's ankle. This is the last piece of the puzzle, right?
It’s like, you know, this is a little bit, you are like, I have done it all once.
Except that little bit
Just like before, I don't know how detailed he is on making this form.
So he thinks this can't be done. But he did not completely rule out that others would not finish him.
and so
I am not a person who will give up, give up something like this.
Try at least once, right?
This is the spirit. This is my philosophy
This may be an impossible goal, but you let go and then you feel the fun, no matter what.
[Brady: "Like your previous movie 'The Parker Square Philosophy'?"]
Yes, he is, you may struggle for a difficult goal.
But you let go, even if you may not succeed
I don't want to make you too excited.
This is not a perfect answer
However, I think he is. He is the perfect answer.
But others may argue with me.
[Smooth Keyboard Music] Why not try it yourself? Create 10958 using 1 to 9 ascending order or see Matt's clever solution (on the screen or in the description link)
One divided by the other, we get pi. Pi is rarely counted in this way because he is very inaccurate